[Música]
con un homenaje a las víctimas
ucranianas y un recuento de los hechos
mundiales más importantes inició la
conferencia de seguridad anual de Munich
al sur de Alemania a pocos días de
cumplirse el aniversario de la invasión
rusa se espera que los asistentes
renueven su compromiso con kiev en la
apertura el presidente vuelo de mimir
selanski pidió ayuda más rápida para el
esfuerzo de la guerra
es por eso que tenemos que darnos prisa
necesitamos la velocidad
la velocidad de nuestros acuerdos la
velocidad de nuestra entrega para
fortalecer nuestra lucha la velocidad de
nuestras decisiones para limitar el
potencial ruso
no hay alternativa a la velocidad porque
es la velocidad de la que depende la
vida por segunda vez consecutiva la
conferencia no tendrá presencia rusa el
año pasado el ministro de exteriores
fue invitado pero No asistió mientras
que las tropas rusas se concentraban en
las fronteras de Ucrania y los líderes
occidentales en Munich instaban al
presidente
Vladimir Putin han invadir hoy la guerra
es una realidad
mantendremos nuestra ayuda todos
aquellos que puedan suministrar tanques
de batalla y armamento Ucrania deben
hacerlo realmente ahora
el presidente francés se dijo listo para
un conflicto duradero e insistió en la
importancia de la defensa Europea y el
apoyo
muy claramente hoy no es hora de
dialogar porque Rusia ha elegido la
guerra
optado por intensificarla por cometer
crímenes de guerra y atacar la
infraestructura
la conferencia no tiene peso político
Pero entre bastidores Se esperan
reuniones diplomáticas principalmente
entre el jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense Anthony belinquen y su
homólogo chino wangie en medio de
tensiones tras el derribo de un globo
chino por parte de Washington